and stuff guys I'm Greg John John we're
looking forward to this and we're
running late to this apologies
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
oh so you never told me I had a purpose
Oh
I'm loving lazy beat Arcanist a hospital
okay
oh I love this
[Music]
[Music]
Oh zero perfect King a comedy troupe
[Music]
yeah Texas has a lot of like the Gotham
surely sometimes episode or the Wayne or
wait it's freaking it was really cool
that was really cool listen guys okay
we're gonna talk about this briefly and
we're gonna do a trailer breakdown for
you guys but I wanted to mention and
before we hop into some thoughts here
wait till after I it would be so great
if you guys could go ahead and follow us
over at our patreon page we do weekly
Q&A is over there as well as TV show
reaction stream along for shows like my
hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood I did all of attack on Titan
almost done with the first season of one
punch man supernatural haunting of Hill
House and of course
Gotham and then there's some shows that
have reaction highlights included those
are one punch man my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and my hero
academia yeah supernatural one of those
there's four of them and yeah we'll be
covering Game of Thrones so be great if
you guys hopped over to our patreon page
Eddy who is some some very quick
thoughts on this
it looks awesome it looks awesome DC has
really taken to shift into a much
light-hearted tough great offense know
that this is this is bringing back a lot
more of that darkness of mean you have
to bring it back to that oh yeah
especially if you're doing Joker I love
this cinematography here this feels like
a filmmakers movie this boy I kind of
get a 70s film but we're here it's in
the 80s but it kind of feels like a
seventies but feels like a 70s movie
maybe about the 80s because I can get I
can definitely get a sense for that
Scorsese vibe that they've been talking
about with this it's a lot more of a
glossy er look like it's not not about
comic yeah yeah like in terms of who's
or the environment around has this more
glossy look and of course walking
Phoenix you know like we who in same
from us like we know a great job okay he
looks just like such a creature in this
trailer and especially the ways that
they're playing up like his weird gaunt
physicality along with all the different
clown looks and stuff like that like it
really looks like a deranged performance
and it honestly did kind of remind me of
like a demented version of you were
never really here the way he's like with
his mom he's like giving her a bath well
it's like that oh that's that's a lot of
king of comedy to me too because of like
the comedian living with his mom yeah
that's an old age take care yeah so a
little bit of that definitely some taxi
driver vibes yeah yeah you know which is
like such a cool combo especially like
just cking comedy get some love you know
yeah in a subtle way but III that those
moments I mean I feel like you got like
two different laughters here that I just
really appreciated because the first
laughter yeah I'm emerging and what's my
is like trying to force himself to smile
because he's all depressed and stuff or
like really lost his soul you can feel
it and that first laughter feels like
force and trying to laugh - like I don't
know high grief or something like that I
can almost that ironic break where yeah
you can do is laugh and then the second
laugh when he's on the subway station is
when he's just really fully cracking
yeah yeah well just so much of his just
physical presence in this trailer looks
like a guy on edge yeah like a guy
teetering between sanity and and I don't
know just breaking inside I love that
he's trying to like form an identity
yeah you know that he's really he's
really searching for an identity this is
this is some great and I think I saw an
image of like I mean I want to save some
stuff for the breakdown because you know
there as I was listening this I was also
hearing some lines here that I'm like
some really great lines
yes sir great a great lines a dialogue
that I was very much into and he did one
of those things where you lost like a
ridiculous amount of weight for your
role and as you should they're gonna be
the Joker too cuz III kind of have it
what's the word I'm looking for here
this doesn't feel like a comic book
movie this doesn't feel like a big
blockbuster by any stretch this feels
like a joaquin phoenix joint feels like
a demented character study crime story
yeah it feels like a grounded crime
story like even just the way he's like
dancing with that gun and like it gives
you a sense of danger without having to
feel like yeah a giant superhero type
battle or something super sci-fi which
is just a cool side of this to pull it
back to yes this feels like the
unsettling yeah type of I kind of get
this impression that he's he's evolving
I think would be Arthur's luck I think
it's his name right I imagine that would
Arthur Fleck in the beginning when
you're watching him I'm like when you're
watching him you know take care of his
mom and who he is first I think it could
be in potentially a transformation where
you're like I really like this guy you
know there's like there's so many little
altercations where people just go out of
their way to be a dick to him so I got
baby play up your sympathy on that too
and really make you yeah feel for him
before he snaps and becomes a
reprehensible it seems like everything's
gonna fall apart because like the
impression I'm getting is you know you
see him that looks like it's on a date
was as he beats or something yeah I
think I met his mom probably dies and
with the when he just loses everything
and this is her city but yeah I want to
go back and like listen to some of those
lines again because the sort of Oz I've
heard like just a bunch of lines are
mature room like dialogue and of course
you know you do see Robert De Niro when
he's about to go and talk poor King
many reference which I very much afraid
it Scorsese yeah I think it's become
appreciated more as time has gone on and
when you sometimes with a self-aware
things I feel like there's a line that
you can sort of cross that's like kind
of off-putting but for this really nah
that's cool direct review why not let it
happen you know well I mean he was
supposed to be involved with this movie
anyway so I I feel like it makes some
sense yes
hey listen before I wrap this video up I
would like to give a patient the day
shout-out to a man named bro and
magazine bro Megson is a very handsome
man from Australia oh yeah and I got to
apologize to you dude the student sent
me a very long message a couple months
ago I replied to it a couple months ago
mm-hm and then he sent me a message a
couple days ago saying why haven't you
replied to me and again the he thought
like I I was offended he thought all
these like these things of and I'm like
what are you talking about I replied
like a whole monologue to you that was
at least three pages worth of reading
material yeah what and then he didn't
get it so now in my inbox is sitting two
replies two different monologues
I have a novel read from him so give me
about a month I will get back to you as
soon as possible buddy I'm sorry that
you were offended I'm sorry that you did
not get my earlier message but I copy
and pasted it and hopefully everything
turns out alright hey I know it's a
weird shout out but I want to put this
out there for the world to know right
guys what do you think of this joker
trailer you excited for the ultimate
Joaquin Phoenix portrait like this he
looks great you guys can subscribe at
the reject nation click that
notification bell and go ahead and check
us out on patreon look out for our
trailer breakdown